this is the SR-71 Blackbird it's one of
the most incredible achievements of
modern engineering it can fly more than
three times at the speed of sound but
more than twice the altitude of a
commercial airliner it's built from
molded titanium and coated in special
paint that makes it almost invisible to
radar and even if it did get picked up
on enemy radar the Blackbird could just
outrun any incoming missiles it's
basically Top Gun in real life just
think about it it flies in Mach 3 so you
can be anywhere in the world in just a
few hours but who designed this
incredible plane why was it made in the
first place and how can technology
companies harness that same Spirit today
this is the story of lockheed's Skunk
Works Division and the man who made it
possible
foreign
Our Story begins in the 1920s in a
sleepy Michigan mining town named
ishqerman the town is named after the
Ojibwe word for in the air this would
prove to be a good omen World War one
was over and this small community which
had proudly sent its men to the front as
part of the 32nd red arrow division was
trying to get back to what it knew best
normality Ishpeming was home to the
Johnson family Peter and Christine had
migrated all the way from Sweden they
settled down and had nine kids one of
them Clarence is the hero of this story
from an early age Clarence loved
designing and Building Things he would
spend hours on end at the local library
devouring books like the Rover boys and
the Tom Swift series by the time he was
12 Clarence had already designed his
first model airplane he called it the
Merlin one battle plane a year later he
won his first prize for aircraft design
spoiler alert it wouldn't be his last
Clarence had found his calling not
everyone however understood this quiet
determined boy at grade school Clarence
was bullied other boys teased him they
called him Clara one morning after the
usual routine started up again Clarence
fought back there was a scuffle and the
bully ended up with a broken leg that
was the last day he was ever called
Clara from then on Clarence had a new
nickname Kelly from a popular song of
the day called has anyone here seen
Kelly he must have liked it because it
stuck with him for Life by the time
Kelly entered the University of Michigan
childhood curiosity had matured into
Brilliance he won two Scholarships in a
single year and worked as an assistant
to the head of the University's
Aeronautical Engineering Department he
was still just as passionate about
airplane design as the day he won his
first prize and his passion was about to
find a perfect Outlet on the morning of
June 21st 1932 a neatly dressed Harvard
grad stood in a courtroom in LA Holding
a single white envelope the judge on the
other side of the bench was responsible
for selling off a bankrupt company yet
another victim of the Great Depression
he asked if there were any bidders only
the Harvard grad stepped forward he slid
the white envelope onto the judge's
bench it contained forty thousand
dollars money cobbled together from a
Consortium of investors it was all he
had but it was enough the judge said to
him I hope young man that you know what
you're doing that young man's name was
Robert E gross the company he bought was
the Lockheed aircraft Corporation and he
would spend the next 28 years of his
life proving that he did know exactly
what he was doing gross's first bet to
resurrect Lockheed was an all-metal
passenger plane called the model 10.
models of the design were sent to the
University of Michigan's Aeronautical
Engineering Department which happened to
have a talented grad student by the name
of Kelly Johnson Kelly conducted the
wind tunnel tests for the model 10.
although his faculty advisors gave the
design a passing grade Kelly wasn't
impressed he took his concerns straight
to lockheed's Chief design engineer Hal
Hibbard by then Kelly had impressed the
people at Lockheed enough to be hired as
a tool designer he was just 23 years old
but he was confident enough to tell the
chief design engineer that the aircraft
which was supposed to save the company
was unstable instead of telling him to
know his place Hibbard gave Kelly a
challenge go back into the wind tunnel
and improve the design after 72 test
runs Kelly came up with the solution an
unconventional twin tail that would go
on to become a Lockheed Benchmark the
model 10 put Lockheed on the map as a
first-class aircraft manufacturer and in
the middle of it all was Kelly Johnson
and his 72 test runs with his work on
the design Kelly was promoted and became
the sixth member of lockheed's
engineering department the model 10
better known as the Elektra was a great
plane in its own right but it was a
modified version of this plane that
became even more significant to this
story the successor in question was the
model 14 the super Electra the super
Electro was a great passenger plane and
its size and speed made it the aircraft
of choice for some audacious record
attempts in May of 1938 a team of
aviators from the Polish national
airline used a model 14h for an
experimental three and a half day flight
from LA to Warsaw via South America and
Africa while the notorious and reclusive
Howard Hughes used a super Electra for
his own global navigation flight the
model 14's Innovative features intrigued
the British royal Air Force they thought
that with a redesign it would make a
good anti-submarine Patrol plane and
with dark storm clouds gathering over
Europe they needed it sooner rather than
later so they gave Lockheed just three
days to rework the model 14. that
wouldn't be the last time that a
government gave Lockheed a super tight
deadline picture the scene a 28 year old
Farm Boy from Ishpeming Michigan is
holed up in a London hotel room with
just three days to design a new aircraft
one that the British Air Force needed
for a war that was looking more
inevitable by the day Kelly Johnson
worked Around the Clock barely stopping
to eat let alone sleep and he delivered
it on time the model 14 became known as
the Hudson bomber a plane which would go
on to play an important role in World
War II where it would be praised by
pilots for its superb maneuverability
officials at the British Air Ministry
were so amazed by Kelly's new design
that they asked Lockheed managers if
they could really entry such an
important aircraft to someone so young
the response was unequivocal Lockheed
had complete faith in Kelly Johnson and
they proved it by promoting him to Chief
research engineer the Hudson was a huge
turning point for Lockheed now when the
U.S government needed a new aircraft
design they knew who to call just in
time too because war was now on the
horizon and it was approaching rapidly
in early 1938 the U.S Air Force issued a
proposal for a twin engine Interceptor
which could operate at high altitude the
accompanying specifications were the
toughest they had ever put out the
aircraft had to maintain a maximum
airspeed of at least 360 miles per hour
and climbed to 20 000 feet in just six
minutes Kelly Johnson believed Lockheed
could do it and he was right but the
design process was the most complex
challenge of his young career he quickly
noticed that at speeds of more than 500
miles per hour air flow over certain
parts of the plane was reaching
supersonic velocity that caused the
plane to violently shake and nose over
into dangerously steep Dives at altitude
turning the model 14 into the Hudson
bomber took a Herculean work ethic
solving this problem needed all of that
work ethic plus tons of problem solving
Kelly Johnson's eventual solution was to
install a dive flap that restored lift
the product of all this tinkering was
the Lockheed P-38 nicknamed lightning
the lightning excelled in combat it went
on to destroy more enemy aircraft in
World War II than any other Allied
Fighter the Nazis called it the fork
tailed devil but Kelly still wasn't
fully satisfied it had taken him years
to iron out that persistent nosedive
problem next time he told himself he'd
do it a different way next time as it
turned out would arrive very soon his
experience designing the lightning
confirmed Kelly suspicions the days of
prop driven aircraft were numbered and
like all good Engineers Kelly had
already acted on his suspicions he had
spent three years trying to crack a code
of jet propulsion so when the US
government needed a jet fighter Lockheed
was in a strong position turning the
model 14 into the Hudson bomber took a
Herculean work ethic powered by two
turbo Jets it could reach speeds of more
than 600 miles per hour surprisingly
though the design was rejected instead
the Air Force opted for the p-59 era
Comet designed by Bell aircraft this was
a big moment Bell was one of lockheed's
main competitors they were applying
pressure and now they were winning
contracts from right under lockheed's
nose Kelly Johnson was angry at the
perceived snug he knew this was make or
break for Lockheed but then fate
intervened the air comet's performance
was so underwhelming that it was deemed
unfit for service and half of the
original order was canceled Bell tried
to revise the design but they were
already swamped with the responsibility
of manufacturing other planes and by
then the pressure to produce was really
on because in the spring of 1943 the
Allies discovered something that
terrified them intelligence showed that
the Germans were conducting Advanced
test flights for an aircraft that could
have changed the course of the war the
culmination of top secret work that
Germany started before the war broke out
the Messer Schmidt was the world's first
fighter jet and the Allies knew that if
they entered the battlefield without a
worthy rival then Germany could gain air
superiority over the Skies of Europe
that wasn't a scenario that anyone on
the Allied side was prepared to
entertain the chief of the Air Force
General Harry Hap Arnold was dismayed
that America had been caught on the back
foot he knew that choosing the mediocre
Bell era Comet was a mistake and he
understood that a second mistake could
prove disastrous so in his hour of need
he turned to the Air Force's most
reliable manufacturing partner Lockheed
Kelly Johnson promised delivery of an
aircraft in just 180 days but he told
his staff that they had only 150 days
their success in meeting this insane
deadline would change Aviation forever
and it would Mark the birth of the
legendary Skunk Works Lockheed was
swamped with wartime manufacturing work
their plants were churning out P-38
Lightnings Around the Clock turned out
to be a blessing in disguise because it
gave Kelly Johnson the opportunity to
test out an idea he'd been toying with
for years he went to Robert E gross the
same man who bought Lockheed for forty
thousand dollars a decade earlier and he
pitched his proposal Kelly wanted to
round up a small group of talented
Engineers designers and Shop people put
them under one roof where they could
collaborate closely and have complete
authority over everything from
procurement to flight testing gross knew
better than to doubt Kelly Johnson so he
agreed and told Kelly to go pick his
people Kelly Johnson tapped about two
dozen engineers and 30 Mechanics for the
top secret work now he just needed a
location he found an old circus tent
near a Lockheed terminal in Burbank
California after the team moved in they
encountered an unforeseen problem the
factory stank the smell got so bad that
one of the engineers jokingly showed up
to work one day wearing a gas mask
another engineer Irv Culver started
saying that the smell reminded him of
the Skunk Works a moonshine Distillery
from the popular comic strip little
Abner that made moonshine from things
like dead skunks and old shoes one day
someone from the Navy called to see how
the Messerschmitt killer was coming
along the project was top secret so team
members were warned to be careful on the
phone the call ended up being
accidentally transferred to Culver's
desk in a flash of wit he picked up the
phone and answered Skunk Works Inside
Man Culver the person on the other end
of the line didn't know what to say
Kelly Johnson wasn't happy about it but
just like a bad smell the name hung
around it was changed to Skunk Works at
the request of the little Abner
copyright holders in the 1960s but in
spirit it stayed the same since that day
in the summer of 1943. the new team had
a hell of a job on their hands they had
to design an aircraft which had never
been designed before they had to deliver
it in 150 days and they couldn't ask for
any outside help the project was so
secretive that you could count the
number of people who knew they were
designing the first true American
fighter jet on your fingers leading them
all was Kelly Johnson who it was the
biggest challenge of his career for all
he knew this could determine the outcome
of World War II and it would be the
biggest Triumph on November 16 1943 just
143 days after work began the first
prototype of the p80 appeared on the
runway at murrock Air Force Base in
California
design centered on a clean fuselage
tapered straight tip wings and a
pressurized cockpit with a bubble canopy
it was nicknamed Lulu Belle after
assembly the new plane was put through
its paces and almost immediately
disaster struck there was a huge Roar as
the inlet Ducks collapsed sending debris
into the british-made h-1 goblin engine
and cracking the impeller the engine
needed replacing but that was much
easier said than done because there were
only two of them in the whole world it
took six weeks of paperwork and
transport until the p80 had another one
inside finally on the morning of January
8 1944 Lulu Bell was ready for her first
Maiden test flight Kelly Johnson told
the pilot to find out if she's a lady or
a witch at 10 o'clock after one false
start Lulu Bell took off and put on a
dazzling 20-minute display the pilot
confirmed that she was indeed a lady so
just how was America's first true
fighter jet created in less than 150
days unquestionably the biggest Factor
was Kelly Johnson he had begun thinking
about jet propulsion years before the
p80 entered service he possessed a
commanding grasp of the technical
details and could seemingly solve any
problem he trusted and respected his
pilots in fact he logged 2300 hours as a
flight test engineer himself and in
Skunk Works he devised a method of
working on top secret projects that
maximized focus and efficiency while
minimizing red tape and political
interference having Kelly on your team
was like a cheat code and now thanks to
him the United States had the p80 it was
dubbed the shooting star in honor of its
speed and streamlined shape it
eventually reached speeds of more than
500 miles per hour despite early
technological challenges the shooting
star was an amazing piece of engineering
that it was developed so quickly made it
a near miracle in the end the shooting
star wasn't needed in World War II by
the time it was ready the Allies had
full control of the skies and the war
was almost over but it would figure
prominently in the early days of
America's Next conflict after World War
II America and the Soviet Union's
reluctant Alliance became an
all-encompassing rivalry known as the
Cold War thankfully the two superpowers
actually never faced each other directly
on the battlefield instead they would
compete on the basis of Technology
ideology and through their proxies the
first time the U.S and the Soviet Union
found themselves on opposing sides was
in Korea and it was there that a
shooting star piloted by an American
Lieutenant Colonel won history's first
ever jet to Jet dogfight by shooting
down a mig-15 what went through Kelly
Johnson's mind when he got that news in
many ways that moment was the
culmination of his life's work a plane
he designed with his own special
projects team shot down an enemy
aircraft generally regarded as Best in
Class and gained an advantage for the
United States and its allies he was the
best aircraft engineer in the world and
he had helped drag Lockheed from the
edge of disaster to what it considered
its rightful place at the heart of the
American defense establishment but there
was no time to reflect or celebrate
because a new adversary presented new
challenges for the United States and the
next one arrived almost right away
American intelligence had revealed that
the Soviet Union had made rapid progress
in developing bombers and ballistic
missiles that could strike targets
thousands of miles away if the Soviets
could achieve this what else could they
be doing this vulnerability was
exacerbated by the fact that the best
intelligence the U.S government had on
the Soviet Union's facilities were
photos taken by the German luftwaffe
during the war that was 10 years ago
virtually a lifetime the conclusion
clear the United States was committed to
Flying reconnaissance missions over the
Soviet Union but they had to improve
their capabilities so the Air Force
created a design competition for a
reconnaissance aircraft that could fly
at 70 000 feet beyond the reach of
Soviet Fighters missiles and radar but
surprisingly Lockheed wasn't invited to
submit a proposal the Air Force decided
to only solicit designs from smaller
companies that could give this urgent
project their full attention this
decision must have come as a shock to
Kelly Johnson and it doesn't look any
better in hindsight the spy plane
required secrecy Innovation and
precision Manufacturing in other words
it was tailor-made for Skunk Works Kelly
Johnson thought the same thing so he
went to Robert Gross and convinced him
that Lockheed should submit a proposal
and that it should be run out of Skunk
Works Kelly got to work combining his
engineering skills with the lobbying
skills he had honed from years of
working closely with Washington his
design named the cl282 could operate at
73 000 feet and had a 1600 mile radius
to save weight and achieve the desired
altitude it stripped out all
non-essential components Kelly promised
delivery within eight months but the
military rejected the design they
thought the cl282 was too lightweight
and that one engine wasn't enough Curtis
LeMay even walked out of one of Kelly
Johnson's presentations muttering that
he wasn't interested in a plane that
didn't have wheels or guns thankfully
that's not where the conversation ended
a panel of experts advising the Air
Force and CIA on the project told them
that the chosen design wouldn't meet the
altitude requirements they thought Kelly
Johnson's cl282 was the superior option
and the CIA agreed they were determined
to win the internal battle they even
roped in President Eisenhower who agreed
that responsibility for the spy plane
should sit with the CIA in the end the
CIA and Air Force came to a compromise
they would go with Kelly Johnson's cl2
282 design but the project would be
jointly managed by the two agencies in
March of 1955 Lockheed received a 22
million contract to deliver 20 CL 282s
the spy plane was made in the shadows it
was given the vague designation of U2
partly because the U1 and u3 already
existed procurement of components
occurred secretly when Kelly Johnson
ordered altimeters calibrated to 80 000
feet from a company whose instruments
usually only went up to 45 000 feet the
CIA made up a cover story about
experimental Rockets shell had to invent
a new type of jet fuel that wouldn't
evaporate at ultra high altitude making
it caused a nationwide shortage of a
certain kind of insecticide yet despite
these hurdles in July just four months
after receiving the contract Skunk Works
delivered the Prototype Kelly Johnson
captured the mood in his logbook entry
on July 15th airplane essentially
completed terrifically long hours
everybody almost dead the YouTube
couldn't be tested at a regular facility
so the CIA developed a top secret
testing site right by the Groom Lake
Salt Flat better known today as area 51.
after completing the first successful
Test Flight of the YouTube legendary
Lockheed test pilot Tony Lavere reported
that it climbed towards the heavens like
a homesick Angel Kelly Johnson and his
team had done it again what's more they
did it 3.5 million dollars under budget
and built an additional six airplanes
out of spare parts the world's first
ultra high altitude aerial
reconnaissance aircraft brought back the
first hard data on the true extent of
the Soviet Union's missile program
photos captured by the U2 alerted the
United States that the Soviet Union was
developing an unmanned Satellite by the
name of Sputnik which changed the world
when it launched on October 4th 1957 and
it was a U-2 flight over Cuba which
confirmed the existence of Soviet
missile launch sites the U2's Pilots
called it the Dragon Lady because it
reminded them of a beautiful serious
character from a popular cartoon strip
the Dragon Lady flew with almost
complete impunity until Francis Gary
Powers was shot down by a Soviet
surface-to-air missile that incident and
the ripples it caused around the world
taught the United States that even high
altitude aircraft were suddenly
vulnerable to Soviet missiles in that
way it accelerated the development of
SuperSonic flight technology but it also
got Kelly Johnson thinking if the
combination of high altitude and low
speed was no longer the answer what
about a plane that was harder to detect
and could fly both higher and faster the
answer to that question was the Lockheed
a12 codenamed Archangel by the Skunk
Works team because it could climb even
higher than the home sick Angel the a12
could fly at more than three times the
speed of sound and as high as 95 000
feet developed by the Skunk Works in
just 20 months in absolute secrecy it
was made of titanium alloy and
supplemented with radar absorbing
composite materials to make it harder to
detect by radar the a12 was so Advanced
that in the words of Kelly Johnson
everything had to be invented everything
for example it was made from titanium
which could better absorb the heat
generated by Mach 3 flight but highly
pure titanium had never been used in
such quantities so new forging and
Milling techniques had to be invented
one of the a12's most important features
was its reduced radar cross-section
physicists working on a secret CIA
project to reduce the visibility of
American aircraft to Soviet radar
developed a theory that a continually
curving airframe would be harder to
track to create the distinctive
cobra-like shape of the a12 Kelly
Johnson added thin curved extensions to
the wings and fuselage however titanium
is brittle it doesn't Bend so much as it
snaps Kelly's solution was simple and
ingenious he machined small triangular
shaped titanium pieces called fillets
into the required shape and then glued
them onto the underlying framework
supplies of Titanium Ore were another
issue lockheed's supplier had only
limited reserves so the CIA conducted a
global search for more using a
combination of third parties and shell
companies the United States government
was able to buy sufficient quantities of
titanium from one of the world's leading
producers the Soviet Union now just
think about how crazy this is the United
States is buying titanium from the
Soviet Union specifically to build a spy
plane to spy on the Soviet Union and
there were literally thousands of
problems like this that needed to be
solved and Kelly Johnson was on top of
all of them the a12 was his greatest
Challenge and one of his biggest
breakthroughs so why was it only in
service for one year the answer is
politics and Technology the Air Force
resented that the CIA had primary
operational responsibility for the a12
if there was going to be a supersonic
high altitude reconnaissance plane the
Air Force's leaders decided that they
should be involved in its development
and deployment the Pentagon agreed and
decided that rather than shift
responsibility of the a12 over to the
Air Force they would replace it entirely
because a superior design had emerged
this plane right here the SR-71
Blackbird to create the SR-71 Kelly
Johnson and the Skunk Works team took
the incredible Foundation provided by
the a12 and built on it the first SR-71
took to the skies on December 22 1964
and entered service in January of 1966.
fundamentally it was a more practical
aircraft its larger size meant that it
could fit a two-person cockpit and a
bigger fuel tank which enhanced its
ability to conduct long-range missions
the SR-71 also carried an extra thousand
pounds of important equipment like
signals intelligence sensors side
looking radar and cameras which enabled
it to conduct reconnaissance without
straying as far into enemy airspace but
this was still a blackbird so we could
really move the SR-71 fluid over 2000
miles per hour four times faster than
lockheed's first fighter jet the p80
shooting star and it could scan a
hundred thousand square miles eighty
thousand feet above the Earth the
sr-71's unique combination of
practicality and performance meant that
even if it was detected it could just
throw on the afterburners and outrun any
missiles screaming in its Direction
Still clad and heat reducing black
titanium it inspired its Pilots
delighted its engineers and unnerved its
enemies with the SR-71 Kelly Johnson and
Skunk Works had achieved The Impossible
they designed an operational aircraft
that flew so high and so fast that it
could neither be intercepted nor shot
down 32 years after it entered service
the Blackbird was finally retired for
good in 1998. none were ever lost or
damaged because of hostile action no
other jet has ever matched its
performance over such a sustained length
of time it was Kelly Johnson's greatest
achievement America's first true fighter
jet the world's first spy plane and a
plane that flew so high and so fast that
enemies couldn't see it let alone touch
it the three crown jewels of Lockheed
Skunk Works division all designed by
Clarence Kelly Johnson as an aircraft
engineer he stands alone but he had many
other gifts he was a brilliant salesman
an effective lobbyist and such an
influential manager that he is often
referred to as the inventor of the kiss
principle keep it simple stupid Kelly
officially retired from his role at
Lockheed in 1975. it wasn't his choice
he was forced by government rules but he
still found ways to make his presence
felt he served on the board of directors
until 1980 and made sure he was replaced
as head of Skunk Works by his Protege
Ben rich and just one year after Kelly
stepped down from the board Lockheed
introduced the first ever stealth
fighter the F-117 Nighthawk the project
he'd LED Kelly Johnson passed away four
days before Christmas 1990 in Burbank
California the same place Skunk Works
began the SR-71 Blackbird was phased out
in favor of unmanned spy satellites but
Kelly Johnson's Legacy wasn't just the
planes he designed it was also the Skunk
Works culture and process he created
whenever you hear about top secret
development divisions like Google X
Amazon lab 126 or even the group Steve
Jobs brought together to create the
Macintosh computer you should think of
Skunk Works today startups like boom
Supersonic and hermius are building the
next generation of high-speed aircraft
if they can harness The Same Spirit
ambition and positivity as the boy from
Ishpeming Michigan did they will
certainly change the world forever
thanks for watching